good morning everyone
today oh my
good morning everyone my name is juliet
morrison and i'm an assistant professor
at university of california riverside
and today i'll be speaking to you about
how lung immune populations
can drive influenza outcomes i will also
demonstrate how
one can actually use gene expression
data bioinformatic tools
and statistical analyses to generate
novel hypotheses
about immune cell involvement in viral
diseases
so for a little background viral disease
severity is determined not only by the
virus but also the host responds to that
virus so it's a very delicate
balancing act which means therefore
that too much of our response is bad
and too little of a response is bad you
have to have a delicate balance
one of the goals of my research is
developing host targeted viral
therapeutics
so what i mean by this is that if you
can imagine that
viruses versus hosts are like children
on a seesaw
in this scenario here we have the host
response
being stronger than the viruses but at
any moment we could have
additional viruses coming in and
overwhelming that host response
if there's too much of a host response
however you will also get tissue damage
and disease
today i'll be talking about seasonal
influenza
it results in three to five million
cases of severe disease and
two hundred and fifty thousand to five
thousand deaths annually
and it causes a great economic burden
about
11.2 billion in economic costs per year
in the us are related to influenza
infections
so i was interested in finding out if
there could be
any signatures that could distinguish
influenza severity
based on their pathogenicity and
serotype across a wide variety of
influenza viruses
and so to do this we combined two
different studies
a very similar design where in one study
we have mice being infected with
different um influenza viruses some
avian and one human
and in the second study we have a
variety of
h1n1 human viruses
and then we take these
data we take this and then we
harvest the lungs from these mice and we
took out
we look at the viral titers and we look
at histopathology and we do
transcriptomics
and additionally we are also taking
weight loss and survival data
once we combine these data
we then integrate everything to come up
with a
larger um a larger
experimental we then combine these data
to come up with a
larger experimental data set
and i want to point out in the
left hand corner i'm showing you a
weight loss curve
of the different viruses in this
particular
compendium we are we have a variety of
viruses that
lead to severe weight loss and death in
mice
so the um sad face with the um crossed
out eyes
we have viruses that can lead to some
weight loss but then the animals recover
and then we have other viruses that
cause very mild
um disease and so the but the mice do
not lose
weight in this situation and so we did
the transcriptomics on the lungs of
these different mice
and we found that we got
we we found that there were increases in
the inflammatory response
in the animals that had more severe
disease
we also found quite strikingly that
there was this
decreasing coagulation and lipid
metabolism
gene expression in the animals that
developed severe disease
and instead we saw more we saw an up
regulation of certain lipid metabolism
and coagulation genes in the mice that
developed mild disease and survived
and this we found we we have highlighted
here in the black box
so what does this even mean well why
are we seeing these transcriptional
differences well
the first thing to consider is that the
lung is an amalgam of different cell
types so we have multiple epithelial
cells we have different immune cell
populations
and we wanted to find out which of these
populations
was causing these differences in
transcriptional responses that we were
seeing
and to interrogate this we used a tool
called digital cell quantifier or dcq
and what dcq does is that it takes an
immune cell compendium from imgen
with many different immune cell types
and then it combines it with
your own gene non-white gene expression
data so
our lung transcriptional data and
then they infer the in viva global
dynamic
changes in the immune cell quantities
within your lung
tissue so basically dcq can predict the
temporal
process of an immune cell response to
stimuli
within a mouse model
after we got the results of the dcq
we then used um statistical analysis to
correlate the presence of these
different populations
from imgen with the weight loss that we
found in these animals
and you can see here
you can see here that we see that
a prediction of lung disease
being decreased as the disease
intensity increases you also see that
pcq predicts um that granulocytes will
increase in the long in more severe
disease
and we also see that alveolar
macrophages are predicted to decrease
in severe disease and monocytes are
predicted to
increase in severe disease and these are
things that we already know
and i'm showing you here how we
validated
some of these results so we take
our mice and we infect them with either
halo9 which is
a mild flu or with pr8 to
give a severe disease or we use pbs and
then we harvest the lungs
at day three and we look at the
different immune populations that were
predicted by dcq
we found that our data matched what bcq
predicted
in that we found that cd11c positive
signal
f positive cells aka alveolar
macrophages
were highly abundant in pbs
infected or pbs controlled mice um
were decreased in our california o9
infected mice
and severely decreased in our pr8
infected mice
we also found that the granulocytes were
lower in quantity in pbs
um treated mice and were
much higher in our pr8 infected mice
as has been shown previously and finally
we also showed
that the lye 6c positive monocytes
are greatly enriched in the lungs of
our pr8 infected mice so
with more severity we see more monocytes
thus alveolar macrophages monocytes and
other immune cell types
correlate with the disease severity
we're discussing here
now i also want to bring your attention
to this population here in green
this is the small puritano peritoneal
macrophage population
so what would peritoneal macrophages
even be doing in the lung
well it turns out that the peritoneal
cavity which surrounds our abdominal
organs
is closely related to two other cerosal
cavities
the epi epicardium as well as the pleura
so the pleural cavity is the
serosal cavity that surrounds our lungs
and in fact the cells of the pleural and
peritoneal cavities are quite similar
both the pleural cavity and the
peritoneal cavity
contain macrophages such as
the small macrophages and the large
macrophages and they're distinguished
by their size as well as their the
markers upon their surfaces
so how do we sort plural macrophages
well in my group we take a live cells
single cells and then we sort
for cells that are cd115 positive and
cd11b positive
and then within that population we
separate them based on
mhc class 2 positivity or f480
positivity
so small plural macrophages are mhc
class 2 positive
and f480 low while the large plural
macrophages
are f480 high and mhc
class 2 low
now for some
real experiments so we wanted to ask
whether
this population that resembles our
peritoneal macrophages
are actually plural macrophages and so
to do this we
we took a very simple approach it's
actually very hard to
um target the pleural cavity but we have
actually developed a procedure in the
morrison lab
where we can introduce dyes and other
things into the pleural cavity without
damaging the lung
so in this experiment we are doing an
intrapleural
injection of a macrophage i call pkh
and when you harvest the pleural fluid
you can see that
we have these red cells here because the
macrophages have
specifically taken up this dye
now if we do that same injection of the
pleural cavity with our pkh and then
follow up with
an intranasal infection with our
with mild or severe flu strains
or pbs we find that
after we remove the lungs and then look
at them under the microscope
we find that we don't see any red cells
in our
pbs treated control mice
but we see a great deal of
red cells aka the plural macrophages
in the lungs of our california o9
infected
mice and there are much lower numbers of
these macrophages in our pr8
infected mice so these are the mice that
get severe flu
and die
and this actually supports our initial
prediction
because we had predicted that in the
case
of severe flu that we wouldn't be seeing
this plural macrophage population
and we further followed up by looking at
the histopathology
of these mice and found that
in the case of our california 09 versus
our pr8 we see a lot more debris
and bronchiolor collapse in our pr8
mice showing that this is indeed severe
flu
versus mild flu
so what is the phenotype of these
trafficked macrophages
well we went ahead and lo did flow
cytometry on
these populations and we found that our
pkh
positive macrophages were actually
actually looked a lot like alveolar
macrophages so cyglic
f positive and cd 11b um
low and we also found strikingly that
the trends the the macrophages that had
accumulated in the lung were also murty
k
negative as opposed to the general
murtik positive macrophages
we're not quite sure what that means yet
but it's an interesting observation
and now if we take the flow cytometry
data and
graph it you can see more strikingly
that
the pleural cavity in the pleural cavity
with the
addition of our viruses we see a
decrease
in the numbers of pleural macrophages
and in the lung we see this increase
of that of the pleural macrophage
populations and specif
especially with our california o9 so we
see an accumulation
of macrophages that originally
originated from the pleural cavity that
and they have now accumulated in the
lung
in the case of mild flu but they do not
accumulate
in the case of severe flu
we then asked if plural macrophages
could have an
impact on influenza outcomes does the
fact that they move
from the pleural cavity into the lung
actually
impact our outcomes
so to do this we injected the pleural
cavity of mice with either
quadrant liposomes or with pbs
liposomes and these hydrogenate
liposomes when taken up by macrophages
will induce apoptosis in the macrophages
so we're basically clearing out the
pleural macrophages
from the pleural cavity and when we do
this
we actually see very targeted
um macrophage depletion because if you
look at the
pleural macrophage population
both the small pleural macrophages and
the large pleural macrophage is
are decreased in the pleural cavity
but we don't see any impact on our lung
macrophage populations
or the populations of the draining lymph
nodes
so plural targeting via with with
padrina
is very very specific for plural
macrophages
so with that in hand we went ahead and
we
did an experiment where we do
intrapleural injections of the quadrant
liposomes versus the
our control liposomes and then a day
later we infect with our mild
um flu strain the california o9
and then we weighed the mice over the
course of five days
and we found that in the case of the
mice that had their pleural macrophages
depleted
they lost weight more quickly than the
mice that
had the control liposomes implying that
the plural macrophages do serve a
protective function
in influenza
we also looked at the viral titers in
the
lung tissue and we found them to be um
pretty comparable for both the quadrant
and the pbsl
untreated mice suggesting that it's not
necessarily a
viral um a difference in the viral
tighter that's driving this and
more most definitely a host response
and um finally i'd like to summarize
what i've discussed today
which is that the plural cavity may
serve as a reservoir for lung
macrophages
and in this case we found that both
small plural macrophages and large
plural macrophages
appear to cross the mesothelium
and enter the lung which is a a very
new um idea furthermore
we know that they are having an impact
on
um influenza resolution and for
influenza outcomes
um how this is happening we don't know
it has actually opened up a much larger
many more questions because we don't
know what's driving the macrophages into
the lung
and we don't know what kind of cells
they're really becoming in the lung
and we also are trying to figure out the
mechanisms of
how it's actually alleviating the severe
disease
and finally i'd like to acknowledge
the members of my group and our
collaborators
who have been involved in this project
thank you so much for listening and have
a good day